what happens when you place dvd copies  of it's a wonderful life in the  clockworks the first copy was placed in  the machinery on the setting one to one  the output was one dvd copy of the film  white christmas the next dvd was input  on the setting fine and produced a dvd  copy of home alone the final dvd was  placed in the clockworks on the setting  very fine the output was a seemingly  ordinary and identical dvd copy of it's  a wonderful life however when the film  was screened for a group of 12 d-class  personnel they all vanished as soon as  the credits rolled they returned 24  hours later six were dead four had lost  their memories and the remaining two  that were lucid claimed to have gone to  a parallel universe where no one  recognized them